what's happening reject nation i'm here
with my buddy our Arshad what up reject nation
what up reject nation you might see him on the
jaby koat channel five years ago but i met him
five weeks ago yeah baby and we just kicked it off
johnny boy is uh in surgery out of commission for
a few days and i said now's the time for a shot
to sneak on in here with me i would not even
wish him better no no no he's like
oh that was the time no screw that
we've never seen the trailer for the atom project
all we know is it's the same people who made free
guy i've been wanting to watch this movie right
when i heard that and i figured we'd get along
yeah so let's watch a movie together let's do it
full length watch as long as we sync with the time
code for the atom project over at our patreon page
become a superior jet by checking out all the crap
we got to offer over there if you don't want to do
that at least you can do is leave a damn like like
and then boys at prepper thank you for helping
us settle down these highlights let's get to it
hal jordan
uh-oh if you don't abort right now i will shoot
you out i'm sorry to interrupt what i'm sure
is gonna be a really scary threat but if i'm
right your tracking system is about to crash
like a video game
oh
wow okay that's another that'll open
it up [ __ ] an audience yeah okay
who are watching on their project
no more jokes oh i'm gonna enjoy this who talks
like that did you order like a bully starter kid
oh oh my god oh and he has an inhaler was
it ray dollar height again it's barely been
a year since we lost his father you could
show some compassion exposition exposition
good exposition if that wasn't anything
he's twice your size everyone is twice
my size i've seen babies bigger than me i
don't understand you dad would and he's dead
it's the third time you've been suspended for
fighting i know you think i'd be better at it
by now this goes on your permanent record do
you get that do you care about your future
he's sassy you're going on a date it's not a date
i i don't think it's a date your dress thinks
it's a date oh it is a date i am going on a date
what am i going on can i please stop saying date
now thanks oh my gosh this is such a smart ass
he's doing such a good ride reynolds
i don't know that's a little good
dog's name hawking hawking like hawkins
from stranger things that's a yeah
spaceship yeah there's some
real like it's something
amblin entertainment lives about this thing
start scoring real quick put the bat down
josh put the bat down i'm not gonna hurt you
i promise what are you doing in here i'm you babe
where's your mother on a date oh with who i don't
know derek derek that's yes the guy with the um
with the mouth mullet the goatee yeah mouthful
i'm gonna get some stuff i'm not careful with
that stay here he got some reflexes that's for
sure if we didn't have a clue so who he was he's
john who is he yeah what is his d like what's his
we don't know yet don't touch my stuff is
this a lightsaber no it's not a lightsaber
okay oh that bullet went
straight through that's good pass
wait wait bullet you were shot yeah no
actually no no i was stabbed with a bullet
what's with the lightsaber it's not a lightsaber
jesus christ adam i need you to play it cool
i know that playing it cool isn't really your
thing oh i said his name how do you know my name
you're adam reid born february 10th do you
go to franklin middle school where you've
been suspended two maybe three times for fighting
which is ironic because you can't fight to save
how do you know my dog's name because
i named him huh where are you going
this is adorable i'm like in it
you're wearing my dad's watch
that's classified but yes
dude you're so lucky you're gonna grow
up to be ryan reynolds that's amazing
yeah that's a dream right there fine can you
at least tell me how you got here i'll show you
she is this is so freaking cute it is that
such a chris has a wonder yeah i love this
if i was little i would probably watch
this movie like every day it has an adc
bit of star man yeah this kid's a star i had no
intention of coming back to revisit this jesus
do you remember this remember what
this right here right now you being
here in 2022 good question you may have just
changed my whole future honestly your future
is pretty tragic either way i'm kidding
i'm kidding i'm not kidding i'm kidding
this is so freaking adorable he clearly doesn't
like who he is on the inside in a lot of ways
oh my god she's in this too i feel like we're
up for one more surprise i knew nothing about
this so this is clearly a novel or a book right
the way it's or it's a great script but it feels
like a book will you be seeing him again no i
don't know i don't think so he's such a he's
such a dick i love this kid hello derek you have a
wonderful mouth mullet and you must be very proud
oh my gosh adam never actually heard it called
that before you can be a real jerk sometimes you
know that this is why time traveled back i mean
it's a little toxic of mom to say that to her kid
just saying he has to know just yes
i'm your mother i'll let you know
oh my god this is like an entrepreneur
this is how your dad did it hey grab a pile
sorry i gotta get to my room to think about
what i've done wow wow call me if you need me
i won't wow dude whatever oh [ __ ] i wonder you
grew up into me and ryan reynolds wow i don't
i don't get i don't see kids represent like
represented like that's mark ruffalo yeah
wow this cast is stacked
dad's favorite song yeah me too dang
look at he's just built he is just built
he's gonna be like day i look good he's
like what i just you're kind of ripped
wait do we get a lot of girls in
college i don't time travel exists
every conceptual idea you have
about the universe has just been
thrown out the window yet your big
question is do i get laid do i jesus
why don't you wear some my dad's clothes what a
beautiful script she's not much of a housekeeper
hey she wakes up every morning with a broken
heart and and a closet full of his clothes and
gets nothing from you but a fistful of crap i'm
here you know tell me about it you know 30 years
you still get sick to your stomach every time
you remember how you treated her now oh boy
jesus
this is this is good dude this is
a good this is a solid ass movie
time after time
hey guys enjoying our suspension i am now oh
that's my spleen i remember these little turd
burpers turd burpers he's got a big mouth i get
it point is this fight needs to happen right now
so here's what you're gonna do you're gonna walk
over there and you're gonna raise your hands
and then you're gonna look ray right in
the eye then you're gonna drop down your
knees and punch him as hard as you
can on the private bathing suit part
i'm gonna smoke your bananas no no no no no
no that's not what we talked about oh god
oh yeah oh my god oh no chuck look we made him
cry he was trying to lose ah you ever hear the
expression every bully has a bully ray if you go
near adam again i'll know i will pull bones out
of your body i will sharpen them and i will use
them to stab little chucky over here what did i do
god i hated those [ __ ] um this is like one
of the best like kids movies in a long time
every bully has a yeah that's my ahmershaw it's
bully you wish those were harry potter you wish
who's this who's who that's my wife laura
you have a wife no we do not have a wife anymore
um oh no thanos's daughter this is this is
babies pure love they grow into teenagers who
grow in to be assassins of happiness thank you
thank you i'm ready for this i wish i knew what
i was doing wrong you're not doing anything wrong
oh my god there's gonna be like a back to
the future thing isn't it no i hope not
i hope this is endearing boys
always come back for their mamas
it sounds like you're speaking from experience i
am you have a good mom my best mom oh jesus christ
aren't you grieving too of course are you so
tell him i don't think he needs no you think
you're being strong for him and the problem
with acting like you have it all together is
he believes it maybe he needs to know let you down
it's okay if you don't
wow that's beautiful my husband had a jacket
just like that this is classic he loves you
well then he knows him he better return
that jacket now it's going to look real
wow man what a [ __ ] amazing script hey hey
what are you going to say i think you're my son
i pieced it together it's a feeling you know
i forgot about all the bad guys the bad guys
find him
so you came back for your wife you're not
getting into that hey she's my wife too
somebody was hiding something maybe she saw
something that saurian didn't want her to see
we're going that way be ready
cool don't you do it don't do it
you want to see something cool
that's electricity
oh awesome
what is happening
oh my god is it her
it is her this is so fun
we should go yep let's go come on come on
come on come on come on oh my god i love this
damn you get a group to be
ryan reynolds and marry her
and that's her new family you've got a great life
ahead of you kids he literally has his parents now
nope someone just died
it's like return of the jedi i'm like in this
they're not leaving they're regrouping
we have to get off this road fast
what road it's like terminator 2 with
them someone went back and altered
the time stream so the future the jet
had left from had already been changed
god it's like i traded my brains for those
muscles saurian must have come back to 2018
and given her younger self some kind of future
intel and get rid of whatever political obstacles
were keeping her from gaining total control
of the time pressure she already had that
but did she no no she didn't it's got a lot of
information even if we correct the time stream
somewhere in us will be the echo of this one
and we will find each other oh i really hope so
i love you that's why i know
you're gonna find me again
it's good to see you bud shoot em we can fix it
by destroying time travel that's right and how
are you gonna do that what's your plan well i'm
not gonna explain my plan to a twelve-year-old
nerd with a dealer because i do not have a plan
dad oh my god so are you in are you
this is so good
tell your husband to get his [ __ ] ass out here
just what do you think is like 100 family
film and it's like tell your husband
man what [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
straight up maybe she missed yeah
maybe she missed like it was a warning shot
hang on
oh my god independence day
this movie has everything
the hottest night club is this movie
did you just turn the plane off
yes i did oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
you really are the best damn pilot we don't pull
this off we're not getting back either one of us
change your destiny
oh yeah
cool can you imagine they cast
mark ruffalo just for the photos
this movie has everything
everything everything's in it
now we see professor hulk
let's go to quote the romans
enjoy yourselves it's later than you think guy
lombardo do i know you just auditing the class
you're my son you're my son i did it i figured it
out didn't i everybody everybody get out of here
something about you serious man in the
back it's deadpool and hulk interact
adam holy [ __ ] what he is smart dad whoa what
happened he knows yeah can you please just shut
up for a second for a second and listen to me
in your face i'm just playing with the theory
that you can use wormholes for time travel but
that part's theoretical right still theoretical
this theory needs to take a leak so let's go
holy [ __ ] i'm the godfather of time travel
stop being a scientist but i am a scientist be
a father you're always more interested in the
universe than you were your own son that's
not true that is true and when you're older
you'll realize that a ship is sailed it's too
late for me so you know whatever i'm fine man
it's ryan reynolds for you it's what it is or you
can get left behind in the past hang up the phone
oh [ __ ] you hate him because he died i think
it's easier to be angry than it is to be sad
and i guess when i get older i
forget that there's a difference
do you get to be so smart
why'd you get to be so dumb
i have good news for you he doesn't need perfect
he just needs you you know i love you yeah i know
i'm extremely lovable she is the best movie mom
of the year of the current times you got time
yeah it's later than you think
she don't know what's up
on your knees i won't tell you again adam what
are you doing i'm about to get my ass kicked i've
been waiting my whole life for this then drop down
and hit him in the private bathing suit after that
nice work
lucky duck that was invigorating oh dad dad i'm
sorry are you okay this close that was amazing
hey hey hey it's your mother's car
i am so keeping this thing
no you ain't little adam feel the vibrations kid
sorry little adam one of two things the
accelerator will continue to run on a dormant loop
or or there's a cataclysmic meltdown that will
destroy all living things within a hundred miles
give me the drive no if i shoot him you die too
adam i'm thinking it over what is
there to say it's a big decision
it's not a big decision i need to think it
through i'm about to lose my [ __ ] here
oh adam get me that drive now
okay
oh he did
i want my tribe you can't have it shoot
him damn in the middle of this do it
maya you're better than this
sorry louis but you brought this on
yourself oh no my uh ask your son how i play
i had to kill his wife twice what
oh [ __ ]
damn [ __ ] i love how ryan reynolds knew that his
face was like oh you never understood the signs
dusted you're my boy and i love you
i love you from the first minute that i saw you
and that will never change adam dad you're my boy
i hate to say it but you
were the best part all along
are we gonna smoke this banana i said play ball
uh some really touching [ __ ] man my throat
oh
but he gets to have the memories this is
how your dad did it hey grab a pile would
ya i'll be late for school oh my gosh
you're right okay have a great day honey
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] me up right here
how you shave his beard he looks 30 years younger
he's been talking for 15 minutes
managed to put the entire class to sleep
you look awake no no no no i've trained myself
to to fall fast asleep but keep my eyes open
what's
are you sure i mean i would
hate to disturb your sleep
i got time clever that's clever
yeah this is so cute uh damn
they did that they did that all their memories
are going to come back yeah like a nightmare
that hit on a lot of real personal notes in
my life oh god damn that was really hitting me
this invited me over to like crying for like an
hour it's just an hour and a half for traffic for
man that was way more heartfelt than i expected
to be yeah i didn't expect anything i thought
i thought free guy you're funny then i was like
wow had a good a lot of moments yeah a lot of
moments i had a lot of heart but then yeah this
was this is like another level of emotion on here
it's like generational father-son storytelling
when do we talk about this we have begun
now we'll uh are we waiting for this to end or
what how does it i guess we're just waiting for
the credits to okay trying to see if they're
copying marvel so much to give us a post credit
scene all right yes we have taken a standing
break for 20 seconds and now we are here talking
that is what is happening in the video
yeah but we are talking who we are
talking about explained it uh that was awesome
it was nice to see ryan reynolds also bring
um his like you know that comedy sarcasm but do a
different character at the same time so yeah a lot
more like i tried watching the other netflix film
he did red notice have you heard of that movie
i've heard of it but i didn't watch it i could
not finish dwayne johnson or ryan reynolds and
i and i was like i'm over this right but this i
i really i really enjoyed his performance a lot
but i thought what was really special about it
and it and i'm sure this movie hits the feels
for a lot of people yeah and i've expressed
this before around the time like around 2013
is when my my dad died so i've was finding myself
like my relationship my dad was not like this
i would say but if on a personal level um you know
and as someone who's been in therapy for so many
years on top of that i was appreciating all the
deeper subtext of psychology they were doing right
like when we become adults we really are just our
childhood selves as in a bigger form right right
so like him coming to confrontation with himself
and realizing like all my emotional [ __ ] stems
from when i was this age right now i'm dealing
with that and of course a lot of that is inherited
by the experiences he has with his father mark
ruffalo you know so you're watching this lineage
of effect and how really the my favorite things
about this movie were the relationships and like
like some of the i like the action scenes but some
of that like big sci-fi mumbo jumbo towards the
end is like that really wasn't like my favorite
parts of this movie yeah but actually like the
least interesting stuff like the more subtle
things with time travel but really it was the
it was the characters the characters it was the
relationships the relationships yeah the writing
and how they changed yeah that's what it was
like the most the writing was phenomenal it was
i can't imagine reading that script and just being
like oh [ __ ] this is really really good it hits
it hits like home on so many different levels in
so many different ways um the nostalgia was great
they had a lot of references there was like
i mean there's a lot of back to the future
some parties of like mark ruffalo was like a doc
brown situation you know um interacting with your
mom uh stop like fly to the navigator they yeah
i'll call out terminator at one point you know
they're star wars i feel like they they i mean
we'll get to we'll get to that like the action
but i felt like they immediately got us with the
scene with the and the with his mom at the bar
yeah and you're like is this going to be played
comedy is this going to be and it was just really
sweet it was just sweet and i was like oh man this
whole movie is going to have these like really hot
like hitting like what is it what is it called
it hits you in the feels yeah like it really just
hits you in the fields every single one of those
family moments well i think what they did well was
like making rod rounds character someone who's
coming to face his trauma right and how that's
just all within himself yeah putting his younger
self on a path to being a happier better person
i like that they didn't keep the dad alive either
right that they were like that's not the point in
the movie is to save the dad the point is how
to cope with the grief right which i thought
was even more powerful that's what i mean like
there's a lot of like there's a lot of family
messages here's so many uh and so i really facing
yourself facing yourself is like the biggest thing
yeah oh that line the one that really started like
the one that started messing me up i remember you
reacted okay but what what was the line it was
the the one about um you're i know why you're
upset i know why you're angry is because he's dead
yeah how it's easy that's [ __ ] me up right now
yeah because yeah it's easier to be anger
is usually a um a defense against something
deeper like right usually something underneath
the anger whether that be sadness or depression
or whatever it's a lot of times it's a defense
mechanism is what it is yeah and then so a lot
of times it's like i remember when i was really
really little if if i had a friend or a family
member who was moving away i would just get mad
at them and i would just treat them like crap
it's harder to deal with yeah it's harder to
deal with the sadness i'm just mad at you now
yeah yeah but you don't you know you just don't
realize that when you're when you're doing it it's
so subconscious yeah like oh you're not like a
little boy going i am masking my sadness with ink
you know and so you're watching him grow
up into that so i think like i said this
really hit this hit home for you yeah i was
hitting home for me in a lot of ways and
um and i thought like the i just thought
that all the chemistry was really good
actually everybody was so good like young
him is so good well who's this kid walker
texas ranger or something you want her to
walk or something or another kid what is
he's phenomenal this kid was great and he was
doing such a good ryan reynolds yeah i was like
whoa like you don't really look like him but yeah
i wonder how that was like i wonder if there was
ryan was like coaching him on like how he would
deliver stuff or if he just like watched a bunch
of ryan reynolds stuff i think that's like it's
not even though it doesn't really look like him
what i thought was cool was that they made sure
the kid at least i think it's first walker it
captures at least the essence of rhyme absolutely
yeah like he had he had the pentameter of him too
and like the just the delivery good word yeah
the warfighter should just say pantameter yes
what does pentameter mean so the easiest way
would be like ionic pentameter is like shakespeare
i'm not even gonna pretend to know
that it ends like yeah that's like
the numbers but yeah pentameter
good good way the way that so
yeah pantameter yeah i love it so i i felt
like that kid really pulled off like that
ryan reynolds delivery and the way he speaks
and mm-hmm yeah he was a little [ __ ] too
he's a little [ __ ] i was like he's this they
made him mean yes he was mean and that's what
i mean is like he hates he hates his he hates
who he is on the inside like ryan reynolds and
that's it but he was in the inside starts at a
little boy agenda right that was like so that was
like powerful that is more powerful than a lot of
people will realize i think yeah i didn't i yeah
and yeah you know like a lot of times i'm talking
with people or like having been like doing my own
little personal help [ __ ] has always been like
oh yeah you gotta go to those little boy wounds
so you got to go to uproot some crap so you can
change it um and then his relationship with even
zoe saldana while not like in it a lot yeah
she's delivered oh my god like her chemistry
around around great chemistry yeah they were
wonderful wonderful chemistry together yeah
i like instantly bought it and for someone
with that short a screen presence yeah you
need to have that kind of instantaneous it's
gotta be good like i believe that love yeah
and that that conflicting choice of like oh
but i might sacrifice us being together if i
if i go back and change this it had such a
potential of getting in the realm of like a
parent trappy and it didn't yeah and it
didn't do that you know like it didn't
because you get what i'm saying like i
had that seriousness i didn't get into
the like super cheese it stayed in a perfect
family-friendly film yeah and i was like i haven't
really watched a family-friendly film in a long
time so it was nice to like see that especially a
live action yeah friendly one it's like the heart
like that that much of heart you know what i mean
a lot of heart yeah a lot of wonder i thought they
captured brilliant like in terms of like it's not
like it does borrow like 80s aesthetic in a lot
of ways i think even with their design i thought
that was in the clothing and everything
about it yeah all all the art although
the way the ships look the way they caught
coloring yeah the coloring especially even being
kind of in the woods for a lot of this uh like
starman that i was thinking of and so they they
really captured that i do think i do think the
villain was underwritten i wasn't a fan of that
right yeah yeah uh i didn't find it threatening or
mentioning it's an adult i just didn't even care
though because i just loved the family moment
so much yeah i was like the bigger [ __ ] was
it was yeah like it was just yeah particle like
celebrate where the hell does thing go magnetic
nobody cares it started losing me a little
bit like the big finale stuff like while it's
enjoyable it it was not the thing that is
great about the captivating at all and it's
like the villain stuff is not that interesting
it's more interesting when they talk about
what they i mean like zoe saw donna ryan reynolds
when they're talking about that's more interesting
than actually right coming to catherine keener and
watching her spout some generic that was a lot of
that was a lot of um like exposition of that part
and it was just like they just told us everything
yeah you know they're just like okay this is
what's happening rather than completely showing
it but it doesn't matter yeah it doesn't matter i
think i was kind of working better when i was just
kind of using my imagination of what the future
is like right but yeah i did think that whole like
big finale thing was i don't know i just didn't
i didn't really need something that explosive
it just wasn't like really cool even though while
there's some good moments in it like i preferred
the action scenes earlier on like the first right
the first time in the woods and we had a variety
yeah there's a good variety of variety and like
those i thought were stronger than even the big
finale one right yeah but the big finale was not
like my biggest my biggest takeaway i just like i
didn't really care for catherine keener i didn't
really like the guy who was the bald-headed dude
yeah like why do they keep building this guy up he
seems like he sucks at what he does he's getting
his ass kicked yeah we're giving him to act like
he's the big showdown guy right like no not really
i do like that catherine keener kills herself in
the end we're just shooting the armor bullet right
that was a kind of uh i was like yeah yeah i i was
like ah you cared more about money than the power
science and if only yeah yeah that cast yeah like
they're like okay and then mark ruffalo is good
they're just like all right let's just let's just
ask let's just keep going but who else can we get
if mark ruffalo was only if mark ruffalo was
barely in it like he was in it pretty much the
last half of the movie yeah if he was you see the
fact that they cast mark ruffalo automatic because
i really didn't know anything about this movie
before so the fact that they cast mark ruffalo
made me go okay so we're definitely going to
see the dad yeah we're definitely going to
time travel at some point to see the dad so that
kind of undercuts some of the like you're kind of
anticipating that happening yeah whereas if they
didn't cast mark ruffalo i uh you'd just be like
oh the dad's play just actually like god yeah he's
like oh we're not doing that yeah yeah but however
mark ruffalo was great at this movie though so i
i was happy he was here he was awesome when they
were doing the scene uh together like the the
ending scene when it's a big touching moment of
him saying that he loves his son when he's you
know one time about google haunting right there
it was like as i'm watching i'm like this is
[ __ ] good and then i was like i wonder how
hard it was for them to shoot this being like so
close see i actually i did get pulled out going
with so many bloopers yeah i literally did that
yeah i did that i was like huh yeah i wonder how
how long this took for them to do
because ryan's like crying in it
and i'm like whoa yeah like they really i
mean they're they're serious actors but like
i i wonder how hard it was because you always see
them in like a comedy version like this was very
touching yeah i wonder how serious they kept this
set i mean their actors who are pro enough to be
able to like still be like yeah yeah between takes
and stuff but yeah i did get a little pulled out
because i'm like i'm sorry you used to see mark
ruffalo doing interviews and being a goofball yeah
right reynolds just like possibly be the goofball
that i was like they must have like ripped each
other a little bit yeah but they brought it i was
like damn that scene was very good will hunting
it was yeah um i would like to see ryan reynolds
in more serious roles like after watching this
i'm like can we can we get some sort of like oscar
type of film to do you know what i mean i think
he would kill it like he hasn't really done all
it's always like a free guy or like a comedy or
something in a and those veins you know i think
i mean that's so the thing with red notice was
that's that's part of why i wasn't i wasn't super
into red notice okay yeah i hadn't seen it so is
that one of the ones that's kind of like i was
serious yeah but a lot of people like apparently
it's like the most viewed movie on netflix but
it's also like ryan reynolds being ryan reynolds
it is like ultimate right now it's like ultimate
right right now i want to see him more vulnerable
like this like i like the base yeah yeah
the mixture of it all like i love his dad
like i loved him and buried and i thought he was
even like amityville yeah buried was good he's
done a lot of he's a i think he's a really great
actor and i even think he brings variety in free
guy yeah but yeah i would like to see him kind of
do a little bit more of these i like when you like
he doesn't have the mask on and doesn't have a
mask on you can see him actually doing the action
too right um but at the same time it's like as
much as this was like ryan reynolds movie it still
felt like an ensemble oh absolutely and i think
that's really cool that like it didn't turn into
solely the ryan reynolds show when i when it could
have been i love that like if i was a little kid
i'll probably watch this movie all the time yeah
like this is such a that like time frame of your
life that you you would watch this over and over
again so it was nice to see that sort of film
absolutely yeah because i haven't seen that in
a long time i'm watching like euphoria and like
crazy [ __ ] like it was nice to like come down
from this like you know let's watch something
that's a little bit more not crazy in your face
all the time and shocking and you know well it's
like one of those pg-13 family films yeah it has
like peril like we just watched the batman like
i was watching the batman and euphoria like
that's where my cinema has gone you know like
this so it's not it was nice to see a brightly
lit film with these primary colors and being like
yeah we don't got to be all like crazy and dark
all the time i look like yeah we do but like
sometimes this is nice i it's uh it's cool to
see a movie that literally all ages can enjoy
like yeah just like you're not gonna be a dad or
a mom who's like i'm gonna sort of watch this for
my kid you know like my mom is gonna love this
i think i think my brother's gonna love this
this could be like an early blockbuster for the i
hope it doesn't just fly under the radar that was
great yeah it was really good and this kid's
a star this kid's a star guys we have done it
we have done it we have talked about the adam
project thank you so much guys for being here
thank you arshad for being here and
i'm saying thank you greg for being you
just edit that part out for
yourself replay it just a clip
thanks for the boys and prepper check us
on patreon your support means
love we'll catch you guys soon